[Music]
[Applause]
why don't you guys why don't you guys
Talk Amongst yourselves while I talk to
the commissioner of Major League
Baseball we'll talk offline because the
commissioner is everything is on the
clock with the commissioner so there's a
there's an answer clock there for him
and uh we'll see if he goes past 20
seconds Rob Manfred baseball
commissioner joins us good to talk to
you again commissioner how are you I'm
good Dan how are you and if you really
want me to answer in 20 seconds I'll do
my best but you know I have a way of
going on a little bit help me understand
the pitch clock and why it's now being
enforced when we've had the pitch clock
why wasn't it enforced
um it was a question of getting in
agreement with the Players Association
um to actually enforce the clock we had
it out there kind of as a guideline to
try to move people along uh but
obviously this year enforcing it with
the ball strike penalty puts it in a
whole different light
give me the feedback that you've gotten
pro and con on the pitch clock and the
the hitters clock okay
um first of all fans
um overwhelmingly supportive of the
change
um there was a Seton Hall poll
independent poll that was done
um recently 80 percent of fans thought
that the new rules were an improvement
in the game that didn't really surprise
us Dan because the rules from the very
beginning were based on fan research
about what they wanted to see in the
game better Pace more action more
athleticism of our players
um in terms of player reaction
um I've met with Tony Clark I've
actually met in small groups with
players from six teams
um
somewhat surprising to me the player
reaction to it has been on the whole
positive the the core of having the
clock
um players seem to be supportive of it
um the issues that players raised I I
consider them to be you know around the
periphery certain kinds of plays you
know a pitcher
um has to cover first base he needs a
little extra time to get back to the
mound the bullpen in Colorado is a long
way away and we need a little more time
to get in from the bullpen we have made
adjustments in response to some of those
issues that the players have raised and
will continue to see player input as the
season goes on
why larger bases that look like pizza
boxes this is kind of an interesting I
don't really think they look like pizza
boxes but um you know they are a little
commissioner sponsorship
yeah well there is that come on
um
we did once do a little stuff I know
that didn't go that well was that spider
you know that Spider-Man didn't go well
but I I would think I'd think baseball
just strikes a deal with you know Pizza
Hut and there you go I wouldn't hold
your breath on that one okay all right
fine the original thought on the basis
was holy safety related
um two different issues one you know
plays around first base when a pitcher's
covering you got different players
converging we thought more room was a
good idea
also the profile of the base right the
old bases were so high the potential for
misstep around them was pretty high
interestingly when we went to the bases
um I think I think the only one who
actually predicted this was Theo Epstein
the even the small change in the size
has actually
um made the running game more appealing
there there's more attempts and the
success rate has gone up so you know
when you change something you may get
effects that you didn't foresee but hats
off to Theo he actually thought that was
going to happen yeah and I love it this
has been my knock uh for a long long
time that you know the Nuance of
baseball was being lost it was I'm going
to throw it really hard and you're going
to swing really hard in that's Major
League Baseball and you're trying to
tell a new generation that's not the way
the game used to be played it was hit
and run there were bunts uh there were
stolen bases and I think one of the
reasons that the reaction both fan and
play here has been positive to the
changes and you know this is an
institution that you know changes not
our long suit in terms of accepting it
um I I think that people have come to
understand that the game had evolved
over a period of time and that we have
tried to position these rules and I
think accurately as an attempt to
restore the best form of the game on the
field
what are you doing with the old bases
could I get one of them for the man cave
here I'll tell you what we'll send you
one how about that I like that one it's
signed or unsigned I wasn't signed yeah
all right
um what are we going to do with the the
neighborhood play
now that the bases are bigger you know
should we get rid of the neighborhood
call here there there's been
um a lot of conversation
um surrounding the neighborhood call I I
think that um one of the things uh
that's important when you have replays
we have never asked the officials to
ignore something they see on replay
and it comes up mostly with plays around
second so they used to ignore the guy
coming off the base right
um when you see it on replay if he comes
off the base they call it I think the
neighborhood play is the same sort of
issue you got to touch the base and I
think once you start down that slope of
telling people we're going to have
replay but some of it we're going to
ignore that's a dangerous place to live
what do you think of allowing us to
listen in on replay
you mean the actual conversation yeah
um well we do we do have a a a little
better transparency on the room this
year
um it does not include live audio
um you know I think that it's important
to give the replay officials an
opportunity to have a free exchange of
views
um before they make the call I don't see
us going that far we are going to have
more insight into what it looks like
when replays going on this year you
could charge you could charge like you
know NASCAR let you listen in on the pit
Crews like your your favorite driver
what if you I'm trying to make you money
here commissioner yeah I I appreciate
the suggestion there's just some places
where
um I I know some doubt this to be true
but there's some places where
um making a little extra money just not
worth it in terms of the risk to the
game and I think that's one of them how
much of this is going to be your legacy
I think the rule changes I I I'll be
honest with you Dan I'm bad at Legacy
questions because I don't think about it
very much I don't know why but I don't
um I do think the rule changes
um based on the reaction that they've
generated will be an important part of
it yeah and I know you're being humble
but I'm looking at this where we bring
in rule changes or you know somebody
does something and there's this seismic
shift 30 years from now
we're going to be we'll be talking about
you know the game and where the game is
I mean it's really important because I
thought baseball was at a Crossroads I
mean I thought you guys were really
lagging far behind
and the little changes I thought I
watched more spring training baseball
this year than I have in a long long
time
and it's my heart good yeah but but
these were all positives now I'm not big
on the shift I think a major league
baseball players should be able to put
the ball in play the other way but what
made you say let's get rid of the shift
I saw this shift a couple of things I
think the shift
um had a disproportionate impact on
certain kinds of players number one
um number two I I think it resulted in
balls that historically fans were used
to be seeing as base hits being outs and
that's not good for the game
um number three you know I got a great
group of former players that work with
us here Raul labanya CeCe Sabathia and
you know I I take a lot of
um guidance from them on these issues
and you know what they were saying to me
is you know it's harder to hit that ball
the other way uh particularly on the
ground which is what you're looking to
do then people realize even for a major
league player last I thought it was
low risk in the sense that from a Fan's
perspective the reaction is going to be
oh I'm looking at the field and it looks
like the field I looked at when I
started watching the game in 1976 you
know I mean it the game would look the
same so there's not a lot of risk
associated with that one talking to the
commissioner Major League Baseball Rob
Manfred all 30 teams would be an action
to start the season tomorrow help me
understand you as commissioner when you
see a spring training highlight social
media sends it out the Phillies game
where the catcher is reaching back for
the ball and then thinks the Umpire is
going to throw it to the mound and then
all of a sudden the catcher gets run
when do you get involved or do you get
involved in a play a moment that went
viral yeah a play like that always
always
um attracts attention here in the
Commissioner's Office the attention that
it attracts is a lot faster than it used
to be because it no shows up on your
phone you don't have to wait for
somebody to you know say you know g-wab
this happened um we we try to pay that
attention to them and okay do you place
a call
no I don't I ordinarily I mean it would
have to be a really big problem
ordinarily I would not I mean I I have
great Mike Hill
um the former
um general manager in the Marlins is an
SVP of baseball operations here he deals
with the umpires on a day-to-day basis
um you know Mike usually will check with
me about what he's going to do but he
does a great job managing that group
okay but how does that happen like what
was done in that situation
look I I think that the problem with
explaining what happened in that
situation is that
um there was I think there was
communication prior to the play that
played a role and we don't know exactly
what that communication was and you know
maybe a little overreaction by you know
a young pirate you know again a learning
experience for everyone involved help me
understand this that we allow umpires to
have their own strike zone
well it feels that way commissioner that
we'd go Eric Greg you know he's really
friendly here and give you the wide
strike or you know when Maddox is on the
mound you're going to get those calls
here but yeah I think that we are I
certainly was around during that era and
I can say unequivocally
um that starting back when Sandy
Alderson was here in the commissioner's
office and I first came in we have made
great strides in terms of promoting the
consistency of the strike zone that's
called by umpires
um our young guys are you know
outstanding on this because they've
grown up in a system where they get
reviewed
um you know on a daily basis literally
get every missed call with a video clip
showing them the missed call after the
game that they must log in and watch and
it has promoted consistency
you know it's way better than it was
um the the question is the question is
you know what's the next step right I
mean do you go further in terms of the
use of Technology because we do have the
technology that literally calls the
rulebook definition of the strike zone
perfectly
I talked to A Minor League umpire and he
said after a while the players they're
fine with it because they want it called
correctly
and I I just see that you can have
umpires but when it comes to balls and
Strikes it's almost like tennis is it in
is it not and there's what do you think
I I think this
um I think like everything else
um there is some misperception as to
exactly what the system is
um you know I get emails from fans
regularly saying you know why do you
want to have a robot umpire well we're
not going to have a robot umpire we're
going to have an earpiece and an umpires
here that tells them what the right
although a robot umpire would be pretty
cool if you want to get the younger
audience commissioner yeah well there is
that but
um that's not how the system works
number one number two I think that
um there
again in the unintended consequence
category there is concern that a certain
type of Catcher who kind of makes his
living framing pitches that you're
de-emphasizing that part of the game
that's an issue we need to think about
and then the the last piece
um you know right now if you look at the
data the umpires call kind of an oval
Strike Zone yeah they don't call you
know inside outside
um on the corners and um that can have
an effect on offense in the game that we
need to really understand
see I think we're I think it's coming I
think it's just a matter of time that
we'll have this and I think once again
you add the video component to this
commissioner and we love bells and
whistles we love that stuff although I
am worried that we have the hitter's
clock and the pitcher's clock and then
we have everything else on the screen
are you worried it gets too cluttered
during the broadcast
we've worked extensively with the
broadcasters
um we we've kind of reached an
understanding that the clock will be
embedded in the bug the scoreboard bug
that's already on the screen
um because we don't want that clutter of
the pitch clock obstructing The View and
we're going to be very careful of about
um the present game presentation of
these changes what's the coolest thing
in your office
the coolest thing in my office is
actually around the corner
um I did a speech at a small College in
New Jersey and there happened to be an
artist who specialized in baseball
players who was an Alum and he did me a
a portrait of Mickey Mantle who was my
favorite player growing up and it's a
pretty neat thing a pretty neat thing
did you meet Mickey
no I my first game was in um that I saw
live I was 10.
um I saw it live in Yankee Stadium in
August in 1968
um they lost to the twins three to two
but man will hit a solo shot from each
side I only know now thanks to Mr
Courtney that it's the last time Mickey
Mantle ever hit two home runs in a game
so so my first game was a pretty good
one a
H doesn't does ohtani feel like Mickey
Mantle
or babe I mean you see how big is he in
your eyes I I I'll tell you
um
maybe the right word is presence
um there is a presence about shohei
ohtani that is out I mean really out of
the ordinary
uh you know he he's
um bigger than people realize in real
life
um and has a real presence about him
um he carries himself with a kind of
Grace that you don't always see in
athletes um we're lucky he's a special
one
why do I have to wait a few more years
now for the WBC
um you know look it's it's a question of
how often we can go to the well with the
clubs and convince them that they ought
to let their last best players go while
they're trying to get them ready for the
season God I I you know what it it was
great you got sentiment on your side and
I and I do think that sense of Pride
that we lost
to Japan and you know it's like when we
lost the America's Cup we didn't even
know what the Americas cup was until we
lost him like damn it we want it back
from Australia I just you're growing the
game yeah I agree with that and I hope
um look I think that um the tournament
was a rousing success from from our
perspective
um you know the fact that we had games
on the you know big fox where you had
four and a half people a lot four and a
half million people in America watching
it we had games worldwide where 65
million people watch that's the most
that's ever watched a baseball game any
kind of game yeah
um those are big wins for us I think um
you know Tony regans who put the US team
together did a phenomenal job and you
know hats off to Mike Trout
um you know Mike committed early he
served as the captain he recruited other
players we did great with the position
players and I hope the next time around
we can build on that and make sure we
have our very best pictures and uh maybe
maybe the gold medal will be the US's
the next time all right I'll wait to get
uh the base signed by you and we'll put
it up in the man cave all right have fun
tomorrow all right thank you thank you
commissioner Rob Manfred we'll take a
break we're uh up against commercial
break back after this